It's see robertson who was
a public works engineer during the building
of the sydney harbour bridge. Do you
remember how you first got the job working
in the public works on the bridge. Yes i
spoke to professor chapman of the university
of adelaide who was my all professor
and i asked him about the possibility of
a job. And he told me that dr
bradfield had just advertised for
draftsman to work. Checking the
design of the sydney harbor bridge
. And suggested that i might
write to him which i did
and you get word back from don't read through
yes i got word back from i don't know
where that was written by dr bradfield
just by his secretary who was kathleen
butler. But any case i got a letter
back from him and told me that dr.
Bradfield would be at the wind chill
in melbourne on such and such
a saturday morning and he would interview
me then and i do course i went over to
melbourne having borrowed the
money from my mother. And
doctor bradford interviewed me. I can't
remember whether he told me at that time
was i had the job or not but the
new case i subsequently received
a notice to say that i
would be employed as
a draftsman. In those days we weren't
engineers we were all draftsman and i
went over to sydney and started about the
beginning of november. I think nineteen
twenty five. No it's fairly accurate and
do you remember what stage the bridge
preparations that got to then the
contract had been let hadn't it. Oh yes.
Constructing the bridge at that stage and
some of the approach bands on the south
side if i remember rightly were.
Almost i think in position one or
one or two of them. I'm not sure about
that but certainly the work had
was well advanced. That stage was no
question but they were proceeding
in the workshops was
a fabrication. Do you member who you worked
under and what it was like in the works
in the drawing office and then yes the
principled engineer i think he was
called was gordon stuckey and
a very clever chap by the way. He was
very good at giving in your instructions
are very good at doing. His
own calculations as well and i gather that
he was one of the leading lights that.
That helped stop the bradfield prepare his
design of an arch on which the tenders
were based as well as of course the
cantilever bridge and do you remember what so
what was your job you were checking the
doormen long that in fact ralph freeman's
office is figures at that stage where you
where we received what we received were
blueprints of various parts of the
structure that's first stage.
The prince of the approach spans and
my first job was to track some of the.
Designs. Well i had to go
over the drawings to get the
trick to get the dimensions of the various
parts of the birch this particular
approach banderas i worked
on and then in light of the
specification check whether any of the
parts were overstressed or not. And
so not many of them were they were all
pretty right. Did you get any into
that argument which they had over how
many. How many good as they would be
in the approach spans there between
britt field and freeman. No
you know i had nothing to do with
that. Past that point in this and
the spans were already
designed to the half below yes
i suppose you might say seeing that they
were being erected my work and checking
some of that was
a fairly academic. But i think. If i can
rightly know it was some of the parts
which actually hadn't been done so it
might or might not have been but. Shortly
after that we received some of the
drawings of the main arch and then there's
was we started checking
those and i think they were
what we were called
a. What they're not stage two
there were several design spread out in
the variations of the design of the arch
and one which we started that i started
on was number two. And there were
a number of points about that which
we found were overstressed slightly
overstressed generally and. This
was sent back to dorman long and
amended it and the next set we
got was rushed for the fourth
trial that this first trial second trial
was the one we worked on first of all and
then the third trial we never saw but the
next one that came was the fourth trial
and this we checked finally and the script
was no more while actually we were still
checking and when the bridge was opened.
That was certainly academic
there wasn't that dr.
Redfield as
a bird but i will amount of checking that
we were doing at that stage was it was
a minor and mainly on.
Details which we felt
for the sake of the record should should
be finished off for for lay people
who wouldn't understand that this
significance of the calculations. If i am as
a layperson but also with some
engineering knowledge but not
a qualified engineer i understand it that
at the time the an arch steel arch in
that situation is what is known as an
indeterminate structure in that if you change
anything in the design the calculations
are going to start all over again because
it changes everything is that right is
that's practically the case although
a minor change would only make
a small change in most
of the structure but
in effect. We found that some
of the. In this second trial.
Some of the members down here.
The spring. That's down is
a pin supported the arch was slightly
overstressed and various other places
they were these were amended in the
in the fourth trial and most of the
checking of that was done before the arch
was actually very far
advanced but during the.
Design work we also checked out the
stresses that each stage of the erection
because the stresses were different
and in some cases where the
fact that what you call the top cord where
that would have been in the members and
compression that is under
a compression stress during
erection. They were hundred tension
stress and these had to be checked. So at
each stage we also checked not only the
final design but also the final condition
of the design that's when you know it was
completed and when and of course also before
the deck went on. We also checked the
stresses the arches were going up and of
course in that case you not only had the
tension you had the weight of the erection
equipment including the big so called
cranes which were hundred twenty. I think
one hundred fifty tonne i think they saw
which was now that there were nearly 600
tons or maybe i'm wrong. There is 580 i
thought something like it might. I'm probably
wrong. I mixed it up with another one
other thing i was interested also. Not
only for the for the bridge but in the
public works office there where you were
you were on the third floor you remember
where you where the drawing office was might
have been the search floor. You don't
remember much about that. Oh i remember
it but whether it was the third floor or
the fourth or the certainly was
more than the second there was
a third floor anyway that whether you're
i think they were all on one floor
bradfield were true officers
there drawing officers one
contained staff which started off well
originally i think there were only three
or four of us and gordon stuckey.
Jimmy holt afterwards.
James and powers who
died about. I think about
a year ago. But let everything go i think
not sure about that anyway. Then there
was no other. Draughtsman tracer and.
Well when i shortly afterwards the staff
increased and we moved to another office
overlooking. Yes the
flats. And in that office.
Finally there would have been about eight
of us all trackings of various portions
of the design and next to
that it was the office where
lush had his staff he was their protest
wasn't he. He was doing the approaches.
They were actually designing the process
originally we were only checking and
included in their staff was. A number of
engineers who subsequently.
Came over to the main
roads as well as. Ones
several health staff
one or two of them went up to brisbane and
one. Engineer who designed that almost
that's steel arch which they took down for
the more than approach was the railway
never used but which the tramways used and
subsequently became also used by either
for the cars. The designer of that
bridge. Joins don't know where
they joined the firm or estada for consulting
engineers and brisbane and i met him
subsequently up there because no in
davies that was. Cardno and davies as
a consultant and i think you desire died
since. Tell me with the. When you first
started where you were working we were hired
by for the public works department or
for the railways. That's rather
a curious thing because both the sydney
harbour bridge and the approaches
were all worked under
the railways and i was
a railway ploy. And as such
i had the privileges which
the railways employers
had. That included one.
Interstate railways pass every
year. And one all lines
. Railways pass here. And
a number of prevent what they call privilege
passes on the railways which. I don't
know how many there were i might have been
only three of two or three of them. I
can't remember how many layers there were
you might better find that out but anyway
these enabled you to travel on the railways
certain times. Usually in your holidays
and you had
a five member item we had three weeks
annual leave and i usually went to adelaide
because my family were there. Although
i think on one occasion i didn't but
in nineteen hundred twenty eight. I think
it was the beginning or twenty eight the
sydney harbor bridge. I
think both the. My in
space and my steel structure and the
approaches i think both were transferred
to the public works department. Yes as
a matter of fact there was an
insight given to me by. By mr.
Harrell peach about that
and he told me that it was
a deal done between bradfield and knew all
about the who was going to take over the
bridge. Afterwards the railways wanted
it but dr bradfield arranged that the
founder main road should have it. Oh that
was subsequently to the opening of the
bridge. I think well according to mr. Mr
piece this deal was done with mr newell
with the main road sport in those days as
early as 1928 and the railways hearing
about it immediately got rid of all you
people. Oh that's that's news to me but i
wouldn't doubt that it's true because
i've i've seen your record cards in the
railways which are in the
archives there and they have
a very unusual thing on them which says to
be treated as service is dispensed with
the words as if you were fired.
Well i don't know about that. I
always heard was simply i can't remember
details but all we heard simply was that
we had been transferred to the
public works department and as
a result of that we lost the
privileges of free railway travel
and i think the public works department
after some urging i should say i think i
remember rightly agreed to boost
our salaries accordingly.
But it didn't this backfire on you later.
What happened to you after the bridge
when we went to the main roads apartment
of course that was in the middle of the
depression and they were glad to have extra
staff on the bridge just because they
had a lot of bridge work and
they were glad to have it for
a few weeks we remained cleaning
up some of the design work.
On the might have been even three months
on the bridge which wasn't very important
but we kept on it and then. We were transferred
onto bridge design work and i would
been on bridge design work ever since
with the deposed i mean road. Not with
a department of main roads up
until 1965 except for roughly
five years during the war when i was
in the air force. And that makes
a big difference isn't it. We got a bit of
a head of myself. There because i wanted
to ask you again during the bridge. Re the
office your it so you had you. They took
actually took up another office in another
building for next day yesterday and we
stayed in the same office. As far as i can
recall we stayed in the same
office and simply transferred.
Bosses from railways to the public works.
I had met the director of public works
but i can't remember his name now but
which one was their work at the time.
Mitchell there was two at
that time i think it was
a little later that i met him i
forget the circumstances now
i had
a great friend who was an engineer who
went through the university was me and he
established. A business. A
manufacturing business for motor car
parts and later or general
engineering called
. Something service engineers in
melbourne and he came over to
sydney on some business and for some
reason of other he was interviewing the
director of public works and i happened
to be with him at the time and i think i
met the director so it would have
been this would have been some time.
After twenty eight anyway i don't remember
when my friend's name is lentz right
stein but whether he's still alive.
I don't know but he's established
a very big firm in melbourne. This isn't
lee later on we went down to the maritime
services board and i met that then chief
engineer devon and i think it was then.
And they took us on
a launch trip out to fort denison and
showed us around there. That's really
is
a go. I just can't remember the details of
it but lance reichs tied and another friend
of mine who both went through the engineering
course and adelaide at the same time
as you know
a chap named keith duncan who since died
i know he has died. They worked on this.
And it became
a very big industrial service engineer this
is the name of the firm in melbourne in
melbourne. Yes that's right.
Incidently lance strike stein
. Before he started this was prince
became principal of the geelong technical
college. The gordon institute of technology
that's right. That's but this is
nothing to do with the harbour bridge.
Fair enough but let's go back then to. How
come you managed to get up the top of the
bridge so often to take photographs as
a it's
a very fine photograph that you took. We
did set of. Stress
measurements on the bridge
at the suggestion of not sure whether it
was gold and stuckey or someone associated
with work suggested that we ought to
check the stresses and we imported for
strain gauges or when i say we i'm sure
whether it was the railways or the public
works but they imported for which
more strain gauges from america. And
we had to go out and prepare the
members in order that we could
use the strain gauges and check whether
the stress had changed what we had to do
was to go out to the workshop and select
the members. And near the ends of the men
we had to drill two small holes about
sixteenth of an inch in diameter
at
a distance of part of ten inches and the
the points of the strain gauge fitted into
these two holes and the points
were connected by two bars.
And join these two bars being
joined by two flat springs
when the distance between
the two hole to hold very
flat springs moved a pointer on
a dial gauge which read two
hundred thousands of an inch.
Or you could estimate to
a hundred thousands of an inch or
better. What we had to do was to take
a reading on the strain gauge while the
member was lying in the shops which would
be the series ready and when the member
went up into the bridge at various stages
of the erection and in the final
stage we had to take extra readings
and see how that. Distance varied
according to that you could check on
the stress in the member. Now this we
did right from the very start until the
bridge was opened. What we had to do
was therefore to have. If there were
four of us. I'm sorry
what i say there were
four of used to go there were four of the
strain gauges therefore and we needed to
one to work the strain gauge and one into
alternate one to write down the results
and we just alternate so as to check
when other now use their strain gauges
on all the arch members on the western
truss. Because that was this side and
where they were going to have the railway
and then surely because the railway
wasn't going to use them. The. Eastern
truss tracks on the eastern side
at that stage had been decided the railway
wouldn't use them. And one sign they
weren't even going to use tramways not. But
they did ultimately use the tramways on
the eastern side. Dr.
Bradfield had to fight
a battle against that and that's one of the
ones he lost doesn't it. Yes i believe
that is so but then in case you ask why do
we had the opportunity to taking photos
. Well periodically we
went out and had these
bouts of taking strain measurements and
while i was there. I took the opportunity
of taking various photos that explains
quite legal to you if you had
a reason to be out there. That's
right. And i might mention that
used to have to climb over the
edge and up ladders and along and
even down into the inside of the cord
the posts which are hollow members and
not inside the diagonal members but we had
to get inside. I'm not sure what we did
that i mean it was i don't know whether
we got inside those or not some of them
might be why we had to go all over the
arch we used to take readings that
both ends of the member right at the top
of the member and the bottom of them or
one in the other end. This is
a check. There were four
strain gauges therefore we
needed. Eight people to work them and
gordon stuckey used to come along as
a general supervisor but he wouldn't stay
there all the time i must mention that it
was very nice when it was
a nice fine day warm but when it
was cold or raining or. In the
middle of it wasn't very pleasant. And
you get the smell of the paint and the
fire drillings we used to wear boiler
suits or put them over our clothes only
. Franklin field said that it that boiler
suits didn't didn't. Didn't wear long
because the knees used to wear out in the
air in the metal drillings that get stuck
in the paint and such. All that didn't
happen to us when we didn't have much of
that we did have some interesting
experiences on the stress. We
went. I say. Down there quite
often and one occasion
we were in
a thunderstorm basics. The
way it was really frightening thought we
knew darn well that lightning couldn't do
with a harbour bridge arch acts like
a sort of lightning direct
arrest the way. Still it was
a little bit scarier this time because the
lightning seemed to be coming very close
at times as one very big
flash certainly very scary
story about ted pitts an it and repeat
this one. Perhaps he was the son of
a minister i think in hobart.
And we were climbing into
a member one day's it takes
a measure and he knocked his head with
a terrible bang against a bit of
a steel word he says bugger. He's
never been able to live it down.
It was a good he got
a you know that.
Nice chap. Tell me subsequently
in the air force and
something i'm not sure he was afterwards
in the public works department at canberra
the federal public works department had
a very senior position you member first
going up in the on the arch from
a first time he went right up to you. We
alright with the heights. First time i
went on the bridge at all. I went on the
approach spans. I'm not sure how that it
was arranged. But i think we just said
gordon stuckey that we might be allowed to
have
a look over the bridge and i think you gave
us permission to go out one day several
of us and i started to climb up
a ladder onto the top of the truss there
were not very much of the decking
there but there were some of the stringers
there in the stringers about that wide
apart. About six feet five feet six
people apart on the railways and
i remember i had to go
a long way in various places they had
planks. But one or two places where we went
we just had to string it as well as i went
up the ladder to the top and i held it
i'm like grim death. And when i got
up there and saw. Well that was it
wasn't very much room to walk across i had
to walk along this thing i got down and
sat down then slid along. I didn't
like the idea of walking but after
a few such trips i found that.
Oh i think probably read
a bit of psychology. You know if you have
a ten inch plank on the ground. You can
walk along it quite safely but without fear
of falling off. But if it's up hundred fifty
feet in the air you think twice about
it. Well after
a while i sort of thought well there but
if i can do it on the ground. I can do it
up in the air so i got used
to it and never worried be.
Even on the arch it never worried me i could
walk all over the place and climb over
it and and much didn't worry me at all.
Was there rather hard to walk up the arch
on the heads of the rivets. It wasn't is
a dangerous slipping off of the pain wet
paint what have you that wouldn't touch it
with paint and that stage
but there were planks and.
On the lower part where the steeper they
had some sort of them of the walkway.
With posts and rope ropes
alongside after it got
to the flatter part they didn't bother
about any way they just kept some of the
ropes but you've got to bear in mind the
top of the arch. It's eleven feet wide.
All those all the members. The main members
are eleven feet wide. I can't put let
me just but so if you walked along in the
middle that you felt you who were miles
away from the engine you didn't worry that
when we went knocking off work and after
stressing and we were up near the center
there while we were coming down the arch
we used to run down. When we
came to this when we came to the
steps you know we used to run down there.
I used to keep my hand close to the rope
a bit takes a slip but you
don't put your finger on
a class but because the rope would cause
little rope splinters to come in and.
Yes it's interesting. Do you member many
of the workmen on the bridge you have
anything to do with them or is it was there
any impression of what they were doing
. We used to see
a lot of them but i think the
book but i don't think i had
any particular reminiscences
about it all. Jem of the
creeper crane drivers i
see you take a photograph
a photograph of the creeper crane up
there. Well i just remember seeing them. I
used to go up there and he used to look
at me and i and eyes wave and say i was
going up and just go like this. And
they were you don't know their names or
anything. Now i never i do know the names
the ones i was vic wilkins now there was
john king. But you had to be
a bit spry because they were all make certain
when you went up there that you were
they were not going to move the crane. So
your move. The jib not the whole crane
the whole crane was only moved
every time they finished
a panel. But the jet used to move across
sea. And you had to be careful as you
might get skittled never see any of the
accidents that happened. You know those
right. Now what can i ask about
that the the public works
pro choose to do you have anything at all
that we have to do with them not nothing
to do with the approach as you know. I
went over them and inspected them with
a couple of engineers on so several occasions.
But nothing to do with the railways
over. No i think that time. Oh little bit
. I forgot. As you go
over the bridge on the.